حضر باحثون وقاده في قطاع التكنولوجيا من
مخاطر الجسيمه على المجتمع والانسانيه
لانظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي دعينا الى وقف
تطويرها لمده سته اشهر الى حين اعتماد
انظمه حمايه منها عن الافاق المستقبليه
لتقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي والتحديات التي
تواجهها وكيف يمكن حمايه البشر من تغولها
وامكانيه التحكم فيه
[موسيقى]
مع ثوره الصناعيه الثالثه والتي تعرف ايضا
بالثوره الرقميه بدا عصر الكمبيوتر
والاتمه حيث استخدمت التقنيات الرقميه على
نطاق كبير وهي التقنيات التي اظهرت قدرتها
على الاستيلاء على قدر من قوه عقولنا
بالاضافه الى مهاراتنا اليدويه لذا فانما
يجعل الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه مختلفه بحق
وقدرتها على دمج كل هذا معا الذكاء
الاصطناعي هو تقنيه تعتمد على عمل
الحواسيب والتي تتطور بسرعه كبيره التعرف
على سلسله من التي تتكرر بطريقه يمكن
التعرف عليها الامر الذي قد يجعله قادرا
على محاكاه الذكاء البشري الاتمته
والروبوتيك هو الاعتماد على الماشين حتى
تساعد بتسريع خطوط العمل واتخاذ بعض
القرارات اللي كان يتطلب وجود بني ادم حتى
يتخذ هاي القرارات الذكاء الاصطناعي
التحول الرقمي بصفه عامه اثبت انه هو شيء
مهم جدا ومؤثر جدا في حياه البشر احنا
الان نعيش احسن تقريبا من احسن اوقات
الانسانيه
للاول لتفعيل خدمه التوصيل عبر الروبوتات
في مقاطعه كامبورغ في مدينه كامبرج والتي
حلت بها الروبوتات في العام 2022 ساهم ذلك
في توفير ما يقدر بسبعه الاف وسبعمائه
وثمانيه وتسعين ميلا من رحلات السيارات
وتقليل انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد الكربون
بمقدار واحد فاصله 670 كيلو جرام الى
الاشخاص عن اعمالهم وهنا تصبح الامور اكثر
ريبه كان المامول في البدايه ان يساهم
الذكاء الاصطناعي في دعم انتاجيه البشر
لكننا بدنا نرى كيف صارت وظائف البشر
انفسهم عرضه للاستبدال لذا اعتقد اننا في
سباق بين مزايا ومساوئ الذكاء الاصطناعي
جدل كبير اثاره لوحه فنيه حملت اسم مسرح
اوبرا الفضاء عندما احتلت الصداره في
مسابقه لمتحف ولايه كولورادو الامريكيه اذ
لم يستطع المحكمون تمييز ما ان كانت
اللوحه من صنع مبدع بشري ام اله ذكيه انا
متخوف من ان تتعرض اعمالي للسرقه
واستخدامها بدون اذن مني الاله مش زي
الانسان من ناحيه الابداع حتى لو تطورت
بتضلها بتترجم كلمه بكلمه اكثر من انها
الترجمه المعاني والسياقات بشكل عام في
بعض الاحيان يكون من الافضل الاحتفاظ
بالقوه العامله البشريه بدلا من الانتقال
الى الاتمته لحمايه مصادر دخل الناس
وتجلينا الان انه لا يمكن الاسته انه
بقدرات الذكاء الاصطناعي فتاثيره
المستقبل فقد اصبح يتماسك مع جميع الوظائف
تقريبا بطريقه
[موسيقى]
تتفوق على الرد المباشر من من موظف للعميل
بالدقه في الاجابه ولكن العيوب لهذه
الخدمه انها لا تستطيع محاوره جميع
العملاء بمختلف
الاجابات هل ممكن انه يتم استبدال وظيفه
اليوم ممكن لكن لا اعتقد ان هذا الشرح
يصير ضمن حياتي انا صراع جديد ما بين
تحديات وفرص يقدمها الذكاء الاصطناعي
للبشريه مما سمح بمزيد من القلق على
مستقبل يغلب فيه ذكاء الاله ذكاء الانسان
الكثير من الاشياء التي يتم تصنيفها على
انها ذكاء اصطناعي ليس الذكيه الى حد كبير
فهي لا تعدو كونها مجرد خوارزميات تعمل
لانتاج مخرجات معينه اعتقد ان هناك مجالات
عديده يكون فيها العامل البشري افضل من
الالات فالذكاء العاطفي وتفسير الاشارات
الدقيقه للسلوك البشري وفهم الامور النفس
يه الى ذلك جميعها يصعب جدا على تلك
الالات فهمها
انه تستبدل الانسان بسبب كتير بسيط انه
الانسان ما زال هو اللي عم يعمل
بعض تطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي قد يفقدنا
الاستقلاليه والخصوصيه ويعرض قيمنا
وثقافتنا للتهديد وحتى ادراكنا لقيمه ان
نكون بشرا صار عرضه للتهديد ان ما نسميه
به تعلم عبر الالات مرتبطون بالبلاك بوكس
ونحن لا نعرف كيف يعملوا الذكاء الاصطناعي
الى هناك عراقيل تعترض سبيل
المجتمعاتها وحمايه الوظائف
وتاثير الذكاء الاصطناعي عندما يدمج في
البنيه التحتيه الكبرى لذلك يجب ان نبطئ
او نبطئ من ذلك
[موسيقى]
التاثير الايجابي الوحيد لكوفيد 19 انه
لفت انتباه للشركات والمنظمات والحكومات
على ضروره التسريع بتبني هاي التكنولوجيا
حتى نقدر احنا نمشي وننمو كمجتمعات
كاقتصادات عربيه لا ينبغي ان تكون الدول
والشعوب والضحايا للذكاء الاصطناعيه فان
كان من الصعب اعاده الامور الى الوراء فان
الحكومات بامكانها ان تلعب دورا في رسم
مساحات العمل الخاصه بها ووضع اللوائح
المنظمه لذلك لازم كل الجامعات يعلموا
طلاب على كيف فيهم يستخدموا هالادوات لانه
هذا التطور اتى ليبقى ونحن اذا بدنا نحن
نبقى كمان على السوق لازم نحن نعرف نستخدم
امل ان يكون هناك حراك عالمي يضع قواعد
منظمه لاستخدامات الذكاء الاصطناعي يدعم
النظم والثقافات والقيم المحليه
لا اعتقد انه من الممكن عرقله انتشار
الذكاء الاصطناعي الا قدام على ذلك سيكون
له عواقب وخيمه على الاقتصاد وسيخلق مشاكل
اجتماعيه ومهنيه السؤال الحقيقي الان هو
كيف يمكننا حمايه البشر من تغول الذكاء
الاصطناعي كيف نتحكم فيه ونطوعه بما يحقق
النتائج المفيده في الشوارع